[Musique]
bonsoir le début d'une nouvelle semaine
d'information locale sur tv 78 très
heureux de vous retrouver pour le
journal de la rédaction tout de suite
les titres de ce lundi 7 décembre
serge morvan devant la justice l'ancien
préfet des yvelines comparaissent
aujourd'hui devant le tribunal de
versailles il est accusé de détournement
de fonds publics faux et usage de faux
dans l'exercice de ses fonctions entre
2015 et 2018 le haut fonctionnaire a
déjà reconnu les faits et devrait
accepter sa condamnation ce week-end
c'était le black friday l'opération
promotionnelle a été reporté en raison
de la crise sanitaire cette année le
bilan est plutôt contrasté avec beaucoup
de petites boutiques qui n'y ont pas
participé
qu'en est il du côté des centres
commerciaux jonathan tout le monde
directeur de westfield vélizy 2 est
notre invité et puis retour sur le
téléthon 2020 le week-end de
mobilisation pour les maladies
génétiques rares malgré l'annulation des
animations locales en cette année
d'épidémie 836 1000 euros de promesses
de dons ont été enregistrés dans les
yvelines un reportage également dans
cette édition du côté de plaisir ou une
passerelle commercial est au coeur en ce
moment de toutes les politiques
[Musique]
il a affirmé qu'il regrettait ces
agissements l'ancien préfet des yvelines
serge m'en rends comparaissait ce matin
devant le tribunal de versailles pour
faux usage de faux ainsi que
détournement de fonds publics des faits
commis dans le cadre de sa fonction
entre 2015 et 2018 qui l' a déjà reconnu
le haut fonctionnaire se voyait notifier
ce lundi sa condamnation les détails
avec astrid berges et à huit mois
d'emprisonnement avec sursis et 25000
euros damende ont été prononcées contre
serge morvan l'ancien préfet des
yvelines comparaissait ce matin devant
âgées du tribunal de versailles dans le
cadre d'une audience de comparution avec
reconnaissance préalable de culpabilité
il ya des faits qui ont été commis dans
une perspective qui était un souci de
discrétion que tout le monde a compris
les sommes ont été remboursées
immédiatement voilà il et les faits sont
retenus avec une ampleur un peu excessif
par le parquet mais c'est le principe de
la crpc
ils sont reconnus au ton tapis je crois
qu'il faut passer à autre chose
pour rappel les faits reprochés
remontent à plusieurs années lorsqu'il
était encore en fonction de 2015 à 2018
l'ancien préfet a produit des faux bond
de mariage fabriquer une fausse
nomination à l'elysée et info ce terme
au g
il a aussi détourné des fonds publics à
des fins personnelles
on parle quand même de 1200 euros de
décence sur trois ans de 2500 euros de
de télépéage sur trois ans et dix mille
euros de dépenses sur trois ans ses
dépenses et à tester non contesté ces
dépenses étaient compensées par le
préfet morvan qui effectué sur ses
deniers personnels des dépenses à
caractère professionnel des agissements
qui lui permettait d'entretenir dans le
secret une relation avec sa maîtresse
c'est grâce à elle que l' affaire a été
révélée
elle a porté plainte en 2018 pour
violences et abus de l'état frauduleux
deux faiblesses et en 2019 les faits ont
été requalifiés dans des termes retenus
aujourd'hui pour la victime cette
audience est une façon de tourner
définitivement la page
son statut de victime ait été reconnu
encore une fois comme je le disais ça
n'est pas ça n'est pas une évidence dans
une procédure de cette nature-là dirigée
contre une personne de cette importance
que la procédure aille à son terme
je pense que l a eu un vrai chemin de
bataille et elle est contente que ça
soit terminé
l'ancien préfet a accepté la peine il
dispose tout de même de 10 jours pour
faire appel
dans l'actualité du nouveau pour la
ligne 18 du métro elle doit relier à
l'horizon 2030 pour rappel versailles à
l'aéroport d'orly dix gares seront
desservies dont à saint quentin est à
guyancourt elle le tronçon aérien on l'a
appris récemment va être quelque peu
retoqué environ 12 kilomètres étaient
prévus en viaduc sur le plateau de
saclay finalement face aux oppositions
locales et dans un souci d'économie la
société du grand paris a pris la
décision de construire une partie de ce
tronçon au sol entre saclay et magny les
hameaux ce qui enlèverait 5 des 12 km de
viaducs et sauvegarderait 4 hectares
supplémentaires de surfaces agricoles
une décision qui divise elle ne convainc
pas les agriculteurs et quelques élus
locaux écoutez la réaction et du maire
de magny les hameaux interrogé par
justine brasier la mise très clairement
ne règle pas la problématique et d'un
transport structurant sur rail vis-à-vis
des populations qui l'entourent
vis-à-vis d'une barrière écologique et
vis-à-vis de l'accès des agriculteurs
on va travailler sur leurs terres et
donc de notre côté bien entendu on
continue de demander une mise en
souterrain
ce qu'on constate c'est qu'au fur et à
mesure des années la société du grand
paris continue de faire des économies
sur le dos des populations rurales jeu
qu'on n'accepte pas elle la semaine
prochaine si la situation sanitaire le
permet le confinement sera levé en
france à partir du 15 décembre
malgré le recul de l'épidémie l'objectif
de repasser sous la barre des 5000
contamination par jour est très
difficile voire impossible hier dimanche
11 mille cas positifs ont été décelés en
24 heures dans les yvelines le recul se
confirme sur une semaine mais les
chiffres restent tout de même élevé est
le nombre de personnes contaminées pour
100000 habitants ce qu'on appelle le
taux d'incidence est en nette baisse
diminution également du taux de test
positif est la pression se relâche peu à
peu sur l'hôpital 60 % des lits de
réanimation sont désormais occupés en
ile-de-france 788 personnes étaient
toujours hospitalisées dans les yvelines
hier dimanche du coc vite 19 60 patients
toujours placé en réanimation est depuis
le début de la crise sanitaire 916
personnes sont décédées dans les
hôpitaux yvelinois 27 décès
supplémentaires en une semaine
[Musique]
pendant trois jours de vendredi à
dimanche c'était le black friday partout
en france un rendez vous commercial qui
cassent les prix juste avant les fêtes
de fin d'année l'opération n'a pas force
n'a pas forcément été suivi par les
petits commerçants yvelinois exemple à
versailles avec michael et demi d'euros
et ses diaga tsongo ici dans cette
boutique versailles est ce pas question
de parler de black friday malgré un
contexte financier compliqué les gérants
n'ont jamais pratiqué ces gens les
d'opérations promotionnelles depuis
l'ouverture du magasin sont eux ce
rendez-vous ne correspond pas à l'image
de ce concept store installé pour les
senteurs sur un taux de confiture qu'on
avait fait fabriquer il ya quelques moi
de vous dire je vais faire 70 % de
réduction ça poserait un problème à
quelqu'un soit aux producteurs soit moi
et après mon client aussi qui pourrait
se dire mais en fait si toute l'année je
paye 70% plus chers
ce commerçant sensations de vol ou de
quelque chose qui marche pas autre
raison invoquée les problèmes de stocks
ils sont bien moins important que dans
les cours aux enseignes
j'ai pas un cargo qui arrive
hong kong pourrait que je pouvoir vendre
à une centaine de mètres même constat
dans ce petit commerce situé rue royale
à versailles le black friday ces
promotions ne sont pas les bienvenus la
raison cette créatrice indépendante
installée dans ce magasin partage et
crée elle même ses produits estime
vendant ses marchandises au juste prix
je calcule le temps que j'ai passé à
fermer produit par exemple à vous avez
l'exemple d'un bracelet manchette en
cuir que j'ai fait j'ai tout bien fait
mes calculs avec les matériaux avec le
temps que j'ai passé à le faire il faut
pas oublier que c'est un produit
artisanal
ce n'est pas un produit industriel il
n'a pas été fait lâche n ya pas de mots
qu'ils ont fait c'est moi qui l'ait fait
voilà donc le prix est juste et donc ya
pas de raison de faire des remises
dessus et le black friday ne devrait pas
s'installer dans les prochaines années
chez les petits commerces versailles et
ils nous ont déjà indiqué qu'il ne le
ferait pas à l'année prochaine et on
continue à de parler de ce sujet du
black friday avec mon invité jonathan
toulemonde bonsoir bonsoir la directeur
du centre de shopping westfield vélizy 2
pour prendre le pouls de ce qu'il s'est
passé ce week-end dans votre site alors
notre journaliste mélanie poker on va
peut-être le voir sur ces images y était
pour faire quelques images a constaté
sur place et qu'il y avait beaucoup de
monde dans les allées du site quel bilan
faites vous de ce week end de black
friday pour vélizy 2 pour huit films
vélizy 2 alors donc le bac friday a
démarré vendredi matin à 9 heures et
s'est terminée donc dimanche soir ce
sont c'est une période où nous
enregistrons une progression de
l'affluence de la clientèle d'à peu près
40% par rapport à une journée habituelle
globalement les commerçants sont très
satisfaits on note une légère baisse en
terme d'affluence mais qui est largement
compensée par un panier moyen et un taux
de transformation qui est supérieur
la majorité des commerçants qu'on a
sondé aujourd'hui sont plutôt satisfaits
et en progression de leur activité par
rapport à l'an dernier
voilà donc plutôt un premier bon bilan
on a vraiment ça peut-être de la
fréquentation par rapport aux années
précédentes on peut l'estimer peut-être
il y avait une certaine crainte à venir
dans les centres commerciaux ce week-end
comment justement vous êtes vous adapté
pour accueillir cette cette clientèle
dans cette période alors on a quand même
des secteurs qui restent fermées ou
partiellement fermée n'est le cinéma les
restaurants soit en sont en vente à
emporter donc peut-être que certaines
personnes plus à risque notamment
peut-être les seniors sont moins venus
mais en tout cas les clients étaient
quand même très globalement au rendez
vous le centre est et était était bien
remplie on est quand même assez rodé
maintenant sur les gestes barrières
depuis la réouverture le mas de la
première réouverture du 29 mai on est
vraiment on a vraiment un large éventail
tout d'abord et c'est pas facile on a
réorganisé les sens de circulation dans
un sens unique s'est largement signalé
par des flèches horizontal vertical nos
clients portent bien sûr leur masque on
a des bandes hors alcoolique au plan
stratégique
on a des distributeurs de masques on a
des agents en renfort qui sont là pour
faire appliquer le sens de circulation
et ses gestes barrières en plus de ça il
ya bien sûr l'affichage des jauges des
effectifs théoriques admissibles sur les
vitrines des magasins
chaque magasin doit donc contrôlée qui
rentre et qui sortent pour tenir cette
jauge de une personne pour mille mètres
carrés et enfin des messages audio sont
diffusés toutes les cinq minutes pour
appeler les messages
voilà et moi j'ai une application qui me
donne en temps réel l'appliquer le
nombre de personnes que j'ai et si
besoin je prêt positionne mes agents et
je ferme des portes si besoin sa pas été
le cas ce week end donc adaptation en
cette période
on imagine c'était une période aussi le
black friday idéal pour lancer la
période importante des fêtes de fin
d'année pour prouver suivent les 10,2
oui c'était très très important de
réouvrir on a perdu un mois de novembre
vu dans sa quasi totalité c'est s'aider
mois extrêmement important en termes de
chiffres en chiffre d'affaires et en
résultat pour une entreprise - une
enseigne donc il était clé d'ouvrir dès
ce 28
voilà et donc on sent que imagine des
des boutiques à recevoir les clients il
y avait une absence vraiment partagé
chez nous chez nos 200 enseignes et
auprès des clients dont c'est vraiment
de se retrouver sur de l'humain sur des
retrouvailles avec l'affairé nouvelles
qu'on avait recréé avec les décorations
de noël
et voilà les gens étaient vraiment au
rendez vous à la fois les commerçants
s'étaient bien préparés et ainsi que les
clients qui étaient nombreux ce week end
on le disait c'est une période aussi
qu'il en soit la période de fêtes de fin
d'année malgré la crise sanitaire ya
quand même un programme d'animations qui
est maintenue sur le site avec une
grande parade de noël qui est organisé
tous les week-ends la traditionnelle
photo avec le père noël aussi en
respectant bien sûr les gestes barrière
ça c'est important malgré le contexte de
pouvoir maintenir ces animations sur
place
voilà on l'a ces dernières semaines avec
toute l'équipe réfléchit à trouver ce
compromis entre la feri noël les
animations le commerce le shopping et
bien sûr les enjeux sanitaires qu'on
connaît donc on a fait des arbitrages
donc il ya des choses très simples le
père noël a dit les espaces et en termes
de fauteuils de l'enfant avec qui va
être pris en photo
on a habituellement un petit train dans
une grande gare c'est quelque chose qui
est traditionnel qui est très attendu on
a fait le choix d'en lever le petit
train qui peut plus circuler dans les
allées qui sont déjà chargés par contre
on a maintenu la gare on a une animation
d'une grande parade avec des
déguisements ne fait pas sur mesure par
une créatrice qui déambulent dans centre
donc ça évite les plans statiques les
regroupements donc on l'a trouvé selon
nous les bons compromis pour créer la
féerie de noël et respecter les enjeux
les enjeux sanitaires une qu'adaptation
on l'a compris en cette période de crise
sanitaire merci je vais t'en tout le
monde est revenue en plateau je rappelle
que vous êtes le directeur de westfield
vélizy 2 merci
[Musique]
on
toujours dans la thématique des centres
commerciaux mais à plaisir avec une
passerelle au coeur de la discorde elle
relie à la galerie auchan au nouveau
centre mon grand plaisir
problème un mur de verre bloquent
actuellement l'accès entre les deux
sites les locataires de cette passerelle
demandent une réouverture pour
redynamiser les lieux les détails avec
ce sujet de mickaël millero depuis trois
ans un plaisir un mur bloquent le
passage entre la passerelle de la
galerie commerciale d'auchan et le
nouveau centre commercial mon grand
plaisir
la raison la liaison n'était pas aux
normes mais depuis début décembre la
commission de sécurité a donné son feu
vert
une bonne nouvelle pour la dizaine de
commerçants la passerelle pu réouvrir
donc le mur est censée tomber ça fait 3
ans en tant que commerçant que les
clients et aussi les riverains attendent
ça et
on a vécu trois ans de galère par
rapport à tout ça une ouverture attendue
également depuis de nombreuses années
par les riverains ils étaient entre 3 et
4000 personnes à emprunter chaque jour
la passerelle avant le mur en fait cette
passerelle il faut savoir qu'en fait
elle ne sert pas forcément pour nous
habitants du quartier que pour accéder
aux boutiques au magasin comme les
grandes surfaces comme auchan mais aussi
pour accéder à la gare est donc en fait
nous sommes très impatients que ça ouvre
dans la nuit de mercredi à jeudi le mur
tombe et il est remplacé par des portes
en verre mais les portes restent fermées
entre les deux sites
donc on a bien des portes comme prévu
mais voilà la surprise du jour
je vais vous montrer en direct ça ne
sombre pas donc nous avons un vigile de
l'autre côté qui fait la surveillance et
nous sommes obligés de faire demi tour
pour accéder au centre de l'autre côté
de plaisir une porte en verre fermer la
compagnie de phalsbourg propriétaire de
mon grand plaisir se défend pour
l'ouvrir la société réclame de l'argent
aux propriétaires de la passerelle
une somme qui correspondrait à des
travaux réalisés sur la liaison par la
compagnie des travaux qui leur
permettait justement d'être conforme des
travaux qui a annoncé les leurs parce
qu'il ne voulait rien et zepa et ces
travaux représentent une somme de 280
mille euros c'est dingue toujours pas
payé elle reste fermée le temps que nous
ayons un engagement écrit leur part
ce n'est pas un engagement de payer
aujourd'hui et tout de suite cette somme
est un également avec un échéance les
gérants de la passerelle et ceux de la
compagnie de phalsbourg doivent
maintenant s'entendre sur le sujet le
dossier pourrait ne pas être débloqués
avant plusieurs semaines
ce week-end c'était le 34e téléthon
l'événement en marathon pour récolter
des fonds afin de soutenir la recherche
contre les maladies génétiques rares
édition particulière en pleine crise
sanitaire avec l'annulation de la grande
majorité des animations source de dons
indéniable rezé lé résultat cette année
un peu plus de 5 millions d'euros de
promesses de dons ont été enregistrés en
ile de france contre 13 millions l an
passé avec 836 1000 euros de promesses
de dons les yvelines se place deuxième
dans les départements franciliens les
plus généreux les bénévoles des
associations locales étaient sur le pont
pour récolter des fonds
à défaut d animation à coignières
notamment comme vous le voyez sur ces
images une collecte était organisée à
l'entrée des magasins à décathlon et
boulanger les propos recueillis par
célia get on go
cette année on a nous avions prévu plein
d'animations et nous devions être la
ville d'ouverture cette année et du
couvent ce on se retrouve à faire
collecter dans les centres commerciaux
de coignières et faire des paquets
cadeaux à boulanger et à décathlon voilà
et on va essayer de prolonger jusqu'à
fin décembre pour collecter encore plus
de fonds pour le téléthon
et justement même si l'édition 2020 du
téléthon est désormais terminée vous
pouvez encore faire des dons en ligne
sur le lien qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran et direction le pecq à présent
une mère et sa fille ça donne en ce
moment à une tâche créer des livres pour
enfants
leur objectif sensibiliser les plus
petits autour de leurs émotions et pour
le second album intitulé pourquoi tu
pleures ce sont les larmes qui on est et
imagée et découvertes avec bixente maria
santisteva c'est le projet d'une passion
entre une mère et sa fille anita et
sarah berdugo ont écrit et dessiné
ensemble pourquoi tu pleures
un album pour enfants ce livre réalisé
pendant leur temps libre et le second
projet mené par le duo familial
cette fois ci c'est les larmes c'était
un symptômes physiques
c'est un sujet qui est encore tabou dans
notre société les gens s'autorise pas
forcément à pleurer et donc on a voulu
et
expliqué qu' il ya mille et une raisons
de pleurer pas seulement quand on est
tristes ou quand on s'est fait mal
destinée aux enfants de 2 à 6 ans
l'album a pour but d'ouvrir la
discussion entre l'adulte et l'enfant
pour lui apprendre à ne pas refouler
c'est l'arbre est très important pour
nous deux que l'enfant n'est pas de
genre particulier pour bien montrer que
conçoit une fille ou un garçon ou
n'importe quoi d'autre
déjà c'est pareil un côté un peu
universelle en fait de l'humain et
l'objectif c'est une pose la question
pourquoi tu pleures
en fait pour que l'enfant lui-même
cuisse prendre la parole et raconter sa
propre expérience
anita et sarah espère avoir autant de
succès que pour leur premier livre le
jardin intérieur de l'est a fondu en
plusieurs centaines d'exemplaires
touchant même d'autres pays francophones
une campagne de financement ulule a été
mis en place afin de soutenir le projet
anita est aidé par deux stagiaires pour
alimenter les différents réseaux sociaux
on a pour objectif aussi dans le cadre
d'une campagne réussie de pouvoir donner
nos livres dans les hôpitaux pour
enfants parisiens à l'hôpital trousseau
l'hôpital necker et l'hôpital robert
debré afin que les enfants hospitalisés
puissent avoir accès à ce monde des
émotions
les objectifs initiaux de vendre 80
exemplaires ont d'ores et déjà été
atteint mais la campagne s'arrêtant le
15 décembre
anita et sarah ou bien l'ambition de
vendre encore de nombreux albums
nous refermons ce journal à montesson un
arbre de la commune pourrait bien
devenir le plus beau de l'année 2020 est
déjà lauréat en ile-de-france ce cèdre
bleu de l'atlas s'est qualifiée pour le
tour national
il a été planté il ya 90 ans dans le
centre hospitalier et théophile roussel
et a vu défiler à bon nombre de
générations d'enfants miquel et demi
d'euros pour vous le présenter
il est en course pour devenir l'arbre de
l'année 2020 ce cèdre bleu de l'atlas
enraciné dans le centre hospitalier
théophile roussel de montesson fait
partie des quatorze finalistes nationaux
cet arbre qui mesure 12 mètres d'eau a
été planté avant la seconde guerre
mondiale dans le parc de cette ancienne
maison de correction pour garçons il a
vu passer des générations d'enfants en
90 ans d'existence
ils ont profité de cet art où ils ont vu
cet arbre ils ont sûrement confier des
secrets ils ont grimpé dans l'arbre
c'est un lieu
vie et de passage on vient s'y promener
on vient s'y ressource et on vient
peut-être raconter des choses à cet
arbre voilà c'est pour ça qu'on l'a
lancé dans cette aventure du concours de
l'arbre de l'année
cette histoire a séduit le jury
aujourd'hui le site est devenu un
établissement de santé mentale et
l'arbre a vu les années défilent et il
porte sur son tronc et ses branches les
stigmates du temps conséquences du gel
et des sécheresses d'une mini tornade en
2016 ou encore de la fameuse tempête de
il a perdu au moins cinq matches au
niveau de la sim
quand il ya eu la tempête et donc
intentions à 12 mètres 50 au lieu d'être
presque 18 mètres qui la veut départ
avec une circonférence que l'on a pu
mesurer que sa liste techniques et
espaces verts de 3 mètres 50 sur
conférence il est comme tout à chacun il
a subi les affres de la vie pour autant
ben il en sort peut-être plus fort mais
il est toujours là il est fort il est
central
il fait partie voilà de notre quotidien
le cèdre bleu compte à ce jour plus de
1250 signature il est pour l'instant
sixième position sur 14
si vous voulez le soutenir vous pouvez
voter jusqu'au 5 janvier
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité belle soirée avec tv
[Musique]